Trascrizione: Jeroen Spooren
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Questa storia inizia quando ero
un bambino di 11 anni,
ed ero appassionato di informatica,
in un paesino della Sicilia centrale.
Potete immaginare che a quei tempi
non era facile avere accesso
a delle informazioni
su un hobby così peculiare.
C'erano gli home computing, però
io ero appassionato di programmazione
per cui era un po' difficile.
L'unica salvezza
era una rivista di informatica.
Qualcuno forse ricorderà:
andavi in edicola, compravi queste riviste
a volte scritte, tra l'altro,
da grandi professionisti del settore.
E una di queste si chiamava
MC Microcomputer.
Aveva un grande staff a Roma.
Una rivista veramente eccezionale.
Ce ne fossero oggi!
Sfogliando questa rivista lessi
di un nuovo paradigma di programmazione
che si chiamava programmazione
orientata agli oggetti.
E il linguaggio di programmazione era
il C++.
E io dicevo, ma sti oggetti che sono?
Il bicchiere? La sedia?
Non possono essere
gli oggetti della vita quotidiana.
Quindi c'è una trasfigurazione
informatica del concetto di oggetto,
ma che sarà mai?
Però, ovviamente non potevo
chiedere quasi a nessuno.
Poi, mi venne in mente che il fratello
maggiore di un mio amico d'infanzia
era iscritto ad ingegneria elettronica.
Era più grande di me, però
io conoscevo il fratello più piccolo.
Per cui mi incamminai,
perché l'unico mio mezzo di locomozione
erano i quadricipiti femorali,
e andai a casa sua.
Suonai e dissi a sua madre:
"Può far scendere per piacere suo figlio?"
Questa dice: "Ma che vuole?"
Comunque,
gli chiedo: "Ma questa programmazione
orientata agli oggetti e il C++,
ma che cosa sono?"
E lui mi disse: "Senti,
la programmazione orientata agli oggetti
è quando la programmazione
inizia a toccare a parlare di filosofia.
Lascia perdere.
Fai cose più semplici.
È un concetto proprio estremamente
complicato da afferrare."
Ecco, per me questa immagine
è l'immagine dell'isolamento culturale.
Voglio sapere una cosa. Ci provo.
Non ho alcuna risposta
e me ne torno a casa a piedi!
(risate)
Ora, questa esperienza
non la ripetei più, assolutamente,
otto anni dopo a Palermo nel quartiere
della Vucciria, dove abitavo,
perché ero studente universitario là.
Erano i primi tempi di internet.
Per sbaglio ho comprato un modem.
Nel senso che volevo comprare
una scheda video.
Sono tornato indietro
con sta cosa che non andava.
Quelli mi fanno: "Guarda,
i soldi non te li posso ritornare."
Allora dico: "Allora, dammi un modem."
Tipo quando compri i carciofi e dici:
"Sono due chili, lascio?" "Lascia!"
Mi faccio dare sto modem,
me ne torno a casa
e con un mio amico iniziamo
a connetterci ad internet.
Ora, io non lo so se qualcuno di voi
nel 95, 96, 97 si è connesso ad internet.
Internet era molto più piccola
di come è ora,
ma sembrava sterminata,
infinita, mastodontica.
Uno non riusciva a credere
che ci potessero essere
tutte quelle informazioni.
Tra l'altro non informazioni
che potevi trovare da un'altra parte.
In quel posto, gratuitamente.
La prima cosa che scaricai
fu un manuale su come aprire
tutti i catenacci e le serrature
di 500 pagine!
(risate)
Si, ma com'è possibile
che c'è questa cosa su internet?
Dopo un po' di navigazione mi resi conto
che esisteva pure, oltre al manuale,
una nova corrente di software
che si chiamava software open source.
Per la verità, ai tempi
si chiamava free software.
Poi c'erano due correnti.
Oggi è conosciuto di più come open source.
Questo open source dava sistemi operativi,
linguaggi di programmazione, database,
completamente aperti.
Non erano solo gratuiti
in termini economici.
Potevi scaricarli,
guardare dentro i codici sorgenti, proprio
l'implementazione come era scritto,
modificarli, rivenderli se volevi,
utilizzarli o così com'erano
o dopo che avevi fatto le modifiche.
Potendo guardare dentro anche capivi come
erano strutturati, come erano progettati.
Era una cosa rivoluzionaria.
Ma dopo che mi concentrai un attimo,
dopo lo stupore iniziale,
dissi: "Per fare questo sistema
che io sto scaricando gratuitamente
in maniera così aperta,
servono decine di persone per alcuni anni.
Ma quindi chi è che l'ha scritto?
Chi sono questi pazzi?"
E facendo una ricerca trovai
che era un movimento culturale,
che era nato in università americane,
perché c'erano delle persone che,
(era nato tanti anni prima rispetto
a quando io ho iniziato ad avere accesso;
là stava esplodendo)
avevano intuito che il software era
troppo importante per essere chiuso,
perchè avrebbe rivoluzionato la società.
Avrebbe rivoluzionato gli armamenti,
l'economia, la medicina. Tutto.
Quindi, ci teniamo il software per noi
solo per una questione economica?
È troppo rischioso!
Volevano accelerare
la tecnologia e la società,
per cui davano software a tutti,
facendo anche grandi sforzi
implementativi
ed essendo loro
tra i migliori del settore.
Poi si diffuse pure in Europa.
Oggi forse, gli Europei scrivono
più open source di tutti gli altri.
Però, il punto era che partivano
da un punto di vista diverso:
di massima condivisione
delle informazioni.
Allora il paradigma economico
era contrario a quello:
io cerco di darti il minimo,
facendomi pagare di più.
Poi, se vuoi di più,
inizio a centellinarlo.
Mi devi pagare ancora di più
e sicuramente non ti svelo i miei segreti,
non ti faccio vedere il codice sorgente.
Se sono il mastro e tu lavori per me,
ti dico giusto quello che mi serve dirti
affinché tu possa collaborare
alla mia azienda.
Di più no, perché se no,
poi mi rubi il lavoro.
Quindi era antitetico al modo normale,
diciamo, di ragionare.
Inizio a usare il software open source
e imparo a programmare finalmente,
otto anni dopo, in C++,
perché avevo un compilatore e potevo
capire cos'è la programmazione a oggetti.
Mi appassiono di sicurezza informatica
e scrivo un piccolo tool,
un piccolo software, che dimostrava
una vulnerabilità in alcuni sistemi.
Io studiavo architettura a Palermo,
non c'entrava completamente niente.
Però, ero appassionato di questa cosa qua.
Allora, mi arriva la prima telefonata
di una lunga serie,
perché prendo questo software, lo rendo
disponibile con licenza open source
e mi telefonano da Milano.
Mi dicono: "Senti,
ma tu vuoi lavorare qua con noi
che abbiamo un team di ricercatori
sulla sicurezza informatica?"
E io rispondo: "Eh, vabbè e perché no?"
Quindi me ne sono andato
da Palermo a Milano.
(risate)
A Milano sono sopravvissuto
forse sei mesi in tutto,
perché poi me ne sono tornato indietro.
Però, in qui sei mesi, mi è successo
un'esperienza importantissima,
perché per me finora l'open source
era questa cosa della distribuzione:
io lo prendo, lo uso e così via.
A Milano, cosa facevamo per lavoro?
Facevamo attacchi informatici
su commissione.
Ti telefona un'azienda e ti dice:
"Vorremmo un attacco informatico".
Ti fai firmare la liberatoria,
se no te ne vai "ar gabbio",
come dicono i Romani,
dall'amministratore delegato,
perché sennò è penale.
Lui, se è furbo, non avvisa il suo team,
perché deve essere tutto reale,
e tu fai un attacco informatico
in piena regola
come se fossi, diciamo, il cattivo,
per vedere se loro hanno
sistemi di sicurezza adeguati a pararsi.
Per fare questi attacchi informatici,
scrivo un tool per migliorarli,
che si chiamava "hping".
Questo hping lo utilizzavamo attivamente.
A un certo punto il mio capo viene e dice:
"Senti, vorrei che non lavorassi più
per i clienti.
Scrivi solo questo hping e rilascia
l'open source, così come stai facendo."
E io dico: "Ma scusami.
Ma se rilascio hping open source,
noi che ci guadagniamo?
Lo regaliamo a tutti?"
Lui mi ha detto: "Tu, non ti preoccupare.
Vai, vai, vai, fallo, fallo."
Dopo un po', ho capito
che il discorso era il marketing.
Perché la ricaduta che noi avevamo
commerciale su questo tool che producevamo
era più importante del fatto
che io passassi mezzo pomeriggio
a lavorare per un cliente.
Per cui l'open source che parte all'inizio
su una motivazione culturale,
se volgiamo anche politica,
di questa distribuzione
dell'importanza del software,
che non lo puoi tenere chiuso,
inizia legarsi al sistema economico.
Perché a questo punto, pure il capo mio
che non era per niente, diciamo,
avvezzo a regalare tutto,
mi dice: "Fai sta cosa".
Inizia a cambiare qualcosa.
E io, per sei mesi lavoro
soltanto a questo tool,
facendo quello che mi piaceva fare
e anche potendolo regalare a tutti.
Quindi, un'esperienza bellissima.
Poi, me ne torno in Sicilia.
Passano alcuni anni.
L'open source a quel punto era diventato
così importante da essere imprescindibile.
In quegli anni, a questo punto
sarà stato forse il 2006,
è quando inizia anche
il sistema operativo Android.
Qualcuno di voi ha un telefono
che gira con Android?
Per il fatto che Android
è un sistema open source,
è possibile per un produttore cinese
fare un telefonino,
infilarci dentro questo software gratuito
che possono scaricare,
e il telefono te lo vendono a 150 euro.
Figurati se devono creare
la piattaforma software da zero,
se il telefono possa costare 150 euro,
o se fosse possibile avere
questa accelerazione della tecnologia,
se ogni volta tutti devono reinventare.
Ormai, l'open source praticamente
era diventato, così come è ora,
la base assoluta
di ogni progetto software.
Avete un decoder Sky a casa?
Ci gira dentro Linux,
un sistema operativo open source.
I macchinari medici sono basati
spesso sull'open source.
Tutte le volte che visitate una pagina web
su internet, dietro c'è un server
che gira quasi sicuramente
su software open source.
Perché l'open source, partendo dal basso,
partendo da un concetto
estremamente anti-economico per i tempi,
ha questo effetto di upwelling e
diventa invece mainstream?
Com'è possibile?
Uno dei problemi è il fatto che i grandi,
anche chi aveva i soldi per investire
in software proprietari,
voleva evitare un problema
che si chiama "software lock-in".
Ovvero, se io a te ti vendo un database,
tu diventi Google
e tutta la tua infrastruttura tecnologica
è basata sul mio database,
io dico: "Vabbò, costava due?
Domani costa 25!"
E tu che fai? Ti cambi?
Ti scrivi tutto da capo?
Adatti tutta la struttura tecnologica
per un nuovo database?
E poi se quell'altro che te lo vende
fa di nuovo lo stesso discorso?
Invece, basandosi su piattaforme aperte,
se il discorso con un fornitore
non ti conviene più,
chiami altri programmatori,
il software è aperto,
il codice sorgente esiste,
e gli dici: "Continuamelo tu!" e così via.
Quindi, per evitare anche il lock-in,
l'open source diventa sempre
più importante
anche nel mondo dell'enterprise.
Ovviamente, la mia start-up,
la faccio partire su software open source,
perché torno in Sicilia
e faccio con un mio amico questa start-up.
La facciamo con l'open source
e dopo un po' facciamo una partnership
con Telecom Italia.
Quando i servizi che noi creavamo,
vengono pubblicizzati sul portale Virgilio
immaginatevi quanto traffico ci arrivava
a cui non eravamo preparati.
E allora, mi serviva un nuovo tipo di
database che potesse gestire questi dati,
moltissimi accessi in un unico secondo,
quindi, che potesse gestire tutto
questo carico di utenti,
possibilmente utilizzando pochi computer,
perché meno computer utilizzi
e più è efficiente in termini economici
quello che stai facendo.
Allora, questo sistema non esisteva
e me lo scrivo io.
Non esistevano né commercialmente,
né nell'open source.
Inizio a fare un prototipo.
Faccio questo prototipo e lo applico
alla mia start-up e funziona benissimo.
E allora dico: "Io sto utilizzando
nella mia start-up
una piattaforma software open source.
Probabilmente, dovrei prendere
questo componente nuovo che ho scritto
e rilasciarlo con la licenza open source."
E però non mi sono fermato là,
perché mi sono fatto prendere
leggermente la mano.
Per cui, per un anno intero
ho lavorato otto ore al giorno
a questa cosa gratuitamente.
Immaginatevi per esempio,
i vostri genitori,
se vedono che per un anno e mezzo
lavorate gratis,
anche se vi arrivano
telefonate di assistenza tecnica,
lavorate con la gente
per risolvere i problemi,
però non chiedete mai una lira!
Ovviamente, è molto lontano
questo modo di operare
da quello a cui siamo abituati
nell'economia reale.
Fatto sta che, proprio per questa volontà
di distribuire tutto gratuitamente,
perfettamente documentato, facendo sentire
anche che io c'ero dietro il progetto,
il software inizia ad essere
utilizzato sempre di più
da grandi colossi dell'informatica.
Instagram inizia a basare tutta la sua
piattaforma su questa cosa che facevo io.
Twitter segue pure,
registrando i tweet all'interno di Redis.
Redis è il nome del prodotto che ho fatto,
non mi ricordo se l'ho detto.
E così via.
Sempre più persone iniziano
a utilizzare questa cosa,
ma per me continuava ad essere un hobby.
Allora, mi arriva un'altra telefonata.
Questa volta da un colosso di informatica
Americano che si chiama VMware.
Magari, qualcuno l'ha sentito dire.
E mi dicono:
"Senti, noi ti vorremmo pagare
per questo Redis.
Vogliamo che diventi un nostro dipendente.
Ti assumiamo con VMware Italia,
(hanno anche una sede pure qua)
e continui a lavorare a sta cosa."
Ma io dico: "Non devo fare nulla per voi?"
"No, continui a fare quello che vuoi.
L'importante è che continui a fare
quello che stavi facendo prima,
ma invece di essere non retribuito,
ti paghiamo noi!"
Uno dice: "Ma la gente
è strana veramente!"
"Sti Americani forse?"
(Risate)
Una volta che inizi a diventare
parte di un sistema produttivo,
il sistema produttivo
non ti vuole mollare,
perché se è un hobby,
poi domani ti stanchi.
Poi, non c'è più Redis.
Per cui alla fine, si creano dei supporti
tecnologici, sociali, economici
e così via,
a far sì che le parti importanti
di un sistema economico
o anche tecnologico
vengano in qualche modo supportate.
E per anni allora continuo con VMware
a sviluppare Redis.
Nel frattempo, Redis diventa
sempre più importante.
Era difficile trovare ad un certo punto
un'azienda che non lo utilizzasse.
Allora iniziano a svilupparsi
le prime società
che vendevano consulenza su Redis.
Più di una.
In particolare, ne fondano una a Tel Aviv,
molto grossa che ora si chiama Redis Labs,
ma prima si chiamava in un altro modo.
Gli ho dato il permesso,
sempre gratis, per chiamarsi Redis.
Sia mai che mi davano un Euro!
Iniziano sempre di più lavorare sull'idea,
perché l'open source e gratuito:
tu lo scarichi, modifichi.
Però, se sei un'azienda molto grossa
e hai bisogno di farlo girare
in un determinato modo,
se ci sono degli esperti che ti possono
guidare è interessante e utile.
Allora, iniziano a vendere Redis su cloud
e a migliorare alcune parti e così via.
Avevano un team di programmatori,
io ero da solo.
A un certo punto, siccome avevamo
un investitore in comune
tra VMware e Redis Labs,
mi dice questo investitore:
"Senti, ma tu, ma che ci fai a VMware?
Vattene a Redis Labs che è dove
fanno supporto per il tuo prodotto."
E passo dall'altra parte.
Mentre la società diventa più grande,
io riesco, anche ora
che lavoro per Redis Labs,
a lavorare solo ed esclusivamente
sulla parte open source.
Continuo quindi, come prima,
ad impiegare tutte le mie energie
per redistribuire tutto quello
che faccio in maniera aperta:
sono su Twitter a spiegare agli altri,
giorno dopo giorno,
che cos'è che sto continuando a fare;
se qualcuno ha bisogno, continuo
a fornire assistenza in maniera diretta;
e così via.
Il sistema della società Redis Labs,
crea quel sistema economico che supporta
lo sviluppo di Redis,
che permette anche, per esempio, a me
di essere pagato e anche i miei colleghi.
Ora in questa storia,
fondamentalmente di upwelling culturale,
perché poi di fatto questo è!
Cioè, quando è iniziato
con l'open source al MIT e Berkeley,
erano quattro fricchettoni,
diciamo la verità,
erano bravissimi loro come informatici,
ma se tu allora dicevi:
"Il futuro dell'information technology
saranno questi quattro pazzi
che regalano tutto"
non ci avrebbe creduto nessuno.
Ma hanno prodotto una accelerazione
tecnologica fondamentale.
L'idea che voglio lanciare oggi, è
che forse nell'informatica l'abbiamo vista
e a questa cosa
abbiamo assistito 30, 40 anni fa,
perché gli ingegneri, chi fa software,
è gente un po' particolare,
ma che magari l'idea della distribuzione
massima delle idee e del sapere
non è una cosa che funziona
solo in quest'ambito.
E se funzionasse nella gran parte
degli ambiti della cultura umana
e ancora non lo abbiamo sperimentato?
Per cui, magari, la prossima volta
che vi capita di fare
una qualunque esperienza umana,
sia essa un'azienda,
un'associazione culturale,
qualunque cosa,
anche un pezzo di teatro
o quello che preferite,
provate a mettervi dal punto di vista
di voler dare accesso massimo
alle cose che fate.
Aprite una gelateria? E allora
ci sono tutti gli ingredienti pubblicati
e persino date delle informazioni
su come fare a casa esattamente quel gusto
e magari su com'è
l'interazione migliore con i clienti.
Oggi quando me ne vado
dal mio ristoratore di fiducia e dico:
"Ma sta carne è buonissima,
ma com'è che fai
a ottenere delle carni così buone?"
e lui mi dice: "Sapessi, guarda, che cosa
faccio per riuscire a trovarti sta carne!"
E no, non lo so,
perché non me l'hai detto.
(risate)
Bisogna cambiare punto di vista.
Bisogna andare a vedere dov'è che ci porta
il punto di vista di concentrarci
sul distribuire al massimo il sapere
e sul rendere tale sapere accessibile.
Perché darti l'Odissea, senza spiegarti
come devi leggerla può essere limitativo.
Per cui io spero che alla prossima volta
che vi accingete a fare qualcosa,
penserete magari all'open source
e come potete applicare
le stesse idee nei vostri ambiti.
Grazie mille e arrivederci!
(Applausi)